she did it again
Germany's Christian Democrats re-elected
Angela Merkel as the party's leader
I accept your choice and I'm pleased
with the result my heartfelt thanks for
your trust Holly
her speech was marked by self-criticism
and pathos makkal knows that she had
demanded a lot of her party and she
warned that the struggle was not over
yet when he found his frustration I
cannot promise that things are going to
get easier because we must do what these
times demand of us she was referring to
her government's controversial refugee
policy which many in her party
questioned she said last year's
migration crisis must not be allowed to
repeat itself and she reached out to
critics by taking a hard line on one
touchstone issue we show our faces in
interpersonal communication that plays a
big role with us and that's why the
full-faced veils does not belong here it
should be forbidden
wherever legally possible it does not
belong in our country
but not even that speech aimed at her
critics was enough to silence opposition
to her course for god it used to be that
what was called the CBO also really was
the CDs this is no longer the case we
have thrown many christian democratic
principles overboard Mackel is up for
the challenge
she has been voted in as party chair for
another two years and wants to be
elected Chancellor once again our heart
beats for Germany and for Europe and for
this we must work for this we must
inspire people each and every one if
possible
that's what I stand for and I ask for
your confidence for this makkal said
that she knows that the upcoming federal
election campaign will be no walk in the
park
but the result of today's CDU party
conference should make it a lot easier